John Carlson was the only man to strike in the
shootout back on Friday night Joe and Craig up
top Al cing your rinkside reporter were off and
running the on I officials the referees are Pierre
lomber and West mccaulay the L's persons Jesse
Marquee and beon Mills San Jose and the traveling
whites McMichael on an early steal rolls one to
the slot that's vacuumed up by zerland the former
devil Maneuvers through Center and play it back
behind Darcy keer keer who was the number one
star in the win most recently boxes this one
out of the air M granin sending in cunan down
the Dasher beaten to the punch there by the Speedy
faravi it's oetkin through center with stro Dylan
stro soer pass Blackwood the stop on Wilson as he
was busting it to the net spectacular stop with
the left pad watch him read it coming across and
there you see Wilson try to slide it underneath
that pad sealed to the ice strongly by their big
goal tender McKenzie Blackwood beautiful touch
from stro yeah TVR lost his stick going after the
forward in the corner now he's playing without one
now they're going to try to feed off of him and
make plays around TV cunan back to the point good
job by Obie giving him his twig switch it up long
wrer just deflected down wide cunan looks to stop
there he tucks it home Luke cunan a hardworking
goal for the San Jose Sharks and then all of a
sudden you know he's involved ean's involved all
five guys get involved touching the puck and an
innocent shot to the net and there's a little play
by oetkin playing catch with ketov his countryman
stro angles in ketov back to stro then oi fine
stop there by Blackwood they've been caught three
Power Play Goals the last three games operating
stro back door Carlson great save by Blackwood
3.9% here's Carlson looking where stro is looking
he's looking back to the sidewall and that frows
everybody I am Ultra confident that I have the
answer I'm just setting myself up for a huge
fall right well we missed last game we need
to come back here today I thought we had last
game so did I this is a San Jose team with a road
gold against average that's ballooned to 4.25 in
this first month of the new campaign mantha with
some speed turning wide Anthony made the right to
the cage he was fouled on his way to the net a
power play coming up after the slash Blackwood
able to stand and hold in there for San Jose for
20 close to 30 seconds here in this game holding
on to it making a play a power move to the net
and trying to slide it past the goalie five hole
there trying to get him sliding opening up the
right PAAD to the rescue no chance for Ruda to
stop the A train he was in full flight what a
great move Backstrom reversing the flow eckan
with a takeaway William eckan knifing to the
net the feed keer a good stop there on granin a
much needed save to keep it a one- nothing hockey
game a stick battle with Keta yeah that's a 50/50
battle in Koo he got a won that one because
Ruda was on his forehand oi one timer kicked
out Blackwood deep in his crease ketov hiding
behind the net elevates the pass to stro stro
Maneuvers K Nets off with his back to the goal
they feed it up top for Carlson stro settles
KET up back to Orkin Stone Wall by Blackwood who
Moved lightning quick and the last opportunity
they totally broke it down look at Obie wide open
he's just slapping his stick by but by then they
have yet to win in the month of October for the
capitals their final game of this month ditto for
San Jose Washington next in action continuing
the home stand with the Islanders Thursday San
Jose opens a four game hom stand with Vancouver
that very same night Phillips posted up along the
wall for the Caps surrounded by Eckland played
back to the point snapshot fought off by keer
Yan Ruda sent on the way this is mantha picking
up speed accelerating down the wing finish there
by Benning who's back in business on the back end
for the Sharks today Nikolai kop held out of the
lineup Jensen looking over his shoulder
Nick Jensen for Washington dangles with
it finds OVI Hardy H oel towards the
goal booted Away by Blackwood Jensen
serves it Strow lets it go he
[Applause] [Music] [Applause]
[Music]
scores then it goes to the half wall and then stro
through a screen with Willie and the defenseman
tied up in front of the net watch stro fire
the puck there's Wilson in line and it gets
by him and he has the sights taken away but
it all started moments before that when the
capital's got a good long range shot granin is
next on The Interchange out of the corner the
Sharks showing a little fiveman cycle work getting
their Defenders involved yeah and that last play
there kudos to TBR he saved the Caps game probably
because it was a two-on one bang bang play there
cunan looking Skyward he had a great chance on
keer Luke cunning the goal score for San Jose
Dyan stro for Washington in it's one-1 duel
sharks putting on some pressure emberson fade
eckan fires kicked out rebound to the corner
and that's why late in the game you just want
to clear the puck caps win another draw Carlson
shuffles the backand that was deflected Blackwood
got a piece of it in five home games this season
including this one the Caps have only scored six
times Wilson back to point position rotation play
Carlton to his forehand oetkin covering from the
point the wrer was blocked tamash Turtle using the
Dasher not going to clear farari anticipated well
Carlson's one time blast deflected doorstep
Wilson backand loose the car [Applause]
in follow the bouncing
biscuit Washington has the 2-1
lead I think everyone knows Tom his 300th
Point here there there's a Ricochet it goes
off of burrows Wilson will get credit for the
goal the go aead goal hard work in front of the
net on a rolling biscuit not once but twice off
the backside of burrows he gives the Caps a two
to1 lead and he notches his 300 points 155 the
time of the tally time continues to run Jensen
sends it on around speed there exerted malen Stein
malen Stein tied up along the boards grin was in
his way but did you see what Valenstein did he
looked up he saw where the red line was didn't
want to get take the icing and then just got it
in two on one cuz Nets off empty nety scores in
the McNugget minute the Caps have a 3-1 lead and
the empty Netter Here Comes Koozie and just puts
it into the empty net the Caps have solved to him
and his mates in the third leank on the goal waved
up there by protus leank cross ice snap shot
denied by keer Darcy save totals up to 29 in
the final 30 seconds second game of a five-game
home stand for Washington closing in on a third
straight win and the capitals will be north of 500
in 15 seconds protus working with leier down the
stretch to the front off of oetkin and booted away
leier plays it on top H octel outside Van Rey with
5 Seconds To Go the snapshot turned aside the Caps
keep the Sharks reeling it's a 31 Washington win